every every comment is this is the most
epic thing so ever freaking awesome what
do you think about the music
which is the super target freak the best
movie i've ever seen what is happening
there reject nation greg and jod here
today gear it up for the batman some
more i love how we've been getting some
news trickling in about this movie we're
gonna watch from 3c films today the
batman test screening reactions plus new
details if you haven't subscribed to 3c
films please do yourself a favor do it
today link in the description box and
pin comment for his channel post
regularly
let's see what the response is for the
batman so far
[Music]
alfred
prepare the batmobile
i'm going to target
[Laughter]
is pretty interesting news we just got
what we're going to be talking about
that's so funny man that was so funny
and we have here our first bit of
reactions from a lucky someone who got
to see the movie and broke their nda
that they had with warner brothers of i
promise i won't tell a single soul
[Music]
and this is all non-spoilers i wouldn't
be making a video about this if it was
spoiler filled so i don't think this
will really i'd watch the spoiler one or
take away any surprises from the movie
but i'm gonna eat your guys opinions
down below what do you think of this
first reaction for the batman reminder
this is only one person's opinion after
the movie comes out everybody can have a
completely different opinion but i don't
know some of the stuff he's saying
really lines up with what i would love
this batman movie to be the source of
how we're finding this out everybody is
questioning but i'm gonna tell you guys
straight up this guy although is not a
scooper is not a journalist or someone
in the industry goes by the username at
blu-ray angel is one of the most
positive heart-warming people in the
batman or movie he had a great great
reaction
yeah that's the yeah even matt reeves
himself the director of the batman
retweeted his reaction to the trailer
when it came out just because the guy
was that ecstatic for it he's the one
that's claiming that he knows someone
who was at the screening and was happy
to tell him a couple little tidbits of
information and then he was happy enough
to share it with us so some people might
be like who the heck is this guy but
trust me when i say this guy's such a
nice positive person in the community i
don't see why he would lie about this to
just bring up some false hope for fans
all right but without further ado i'm so
glad you said that chris found out about
with the movie overall round off quote
to how to describe the batman he says is
the batman movie is a horror movie a
horror very graphic very dark very scary
paul dano is effing crazy so effing
scary i love every second i've always
thought the batman totally lends itself
to if not like a horror movie but at
least a psychological thriller like
something that feels suspenseful and
horror-esque horror adjacent so to come
out and say that this is a horror movie
directly i'm sure that it has to at
least be the vibe of the dark and
menacing undertones i think we said that
in the trailer reaction that we first
and we might have that there we got some
horror movie vibes from it okay so to
hear that is very satisfying and you
just read this one thing about paul dano
right away saying how scary he is like
if there's anyone who i can believe is
scary as the riddler's paw daddo
absolutely i've never actually seen an
interview with that guy anything he does
i'm i he just gives off creepy vibes all
the time always no matter how even if
it's like a sincere tender character
like i don't know man you still kind of
creep me out i don't know what it is
about you don't be afraid to approach
paul dano in real life but i love
hearing this already there's one little
quote the riddler in this movie is going
to be putting their victims in jigsaw
jigsaw-like scenarios where if they want
to make it out alive they have to
complete some sort of task specifically
like we see there's a guy who has a bomb
implanted on him and he has to drive
through what seems to be a funeral and
hand a message to the batman
thinking about the fact that someone is
literally gonna get their face duct
taped up and either that's how they die
from suffocation or that's just what he
does after the body is dead that seems
like something very sadistic yeah and
it's finally a side of batman we haven't
seen all that much about because we saw
in the trailer just how badly he beat up
one of the thugs that'll be part of this
movie and at cinemacon they revealed a
little bit more of footage and robert
pattinson along with that footage was
saying that batman is basically taking
out his anger on criminals makes it feel
a little personal so it's not just gonna
be the riddler scaring us up i think
this batman will be fronting actually i
like what you're saying about some of
the fear might be coming from but the
whole point of batman is to invoke fear
upon criminals too we don't really get
that vibe sometimes you get movies that
like touch on that and remember even
like when batman begins when scarecrow
gets hit with his own toxin in the way
he's seeing batman or when you shift to
the perspective of the criminals how
they're afraid of him the idea of
watching a batman who's so on edge that
you're kind of worried about him
crossing the line or going too far does
create this atmosphere of tension that
could be a lot more suspenseful for your
film oh yeah i would love that idea of
riding a lot of the tension off of just
how erratic batman is coming across and
how unhinged in his anger and rage that
he is there's already so much horror in
the rogues gallery and it makes perfect
sense to match that with horror coming
from bruce absolutely it's all about you
know where his soul hangs
it's upside down like a bat
the cut they saw of the batman is three
hours long
a three hour long batman movie that is
as much batman as i would i'd love it to
be three hours let's do it let me know
the story in this movie has to be pretty
meaty to fill up that three-hour leg now
keep in mind this is an early rough cut
of the movie the purpose of these test
screenings is so that they can figure
out what works in the movie what doesn't
work with it get josh reading in there
lighten it up
it might be 10 15 minutes below that but
still if the movie is nearing three
hours that's a good sign that plenty of
batman is headed our way if there's one
thing i'm getting from the fact that
it's three hours long they're probably
gonna trim it down but if the audience
response is as strong as just this one
guy who we're honing in on right now i
can only imagine that perhaps we could
get an extended cut when the blue rake
does come around which would be pretty
sweet or a 2 hour and 55 minute
theatrical cut their thoughts on zoey
kravitz as catwoman i have a million
things to say about catwoman she's my
favorite holy
definitely my favorite cat woman and i
feel like that says a lot because we've
had tons of live-action cat womans in
the back don't you dare disrespect my
halle berry
series to michael keaton's batman to
then christian bales batman and now
we're getting zoe kravis's catwoman i'm
really curious to see what
differentiates her from all the other
cat women's of the past are they gonna
play up that whole love relationship
like they love to do batman movies with
catwoman and batman or will this be
different where it is more of a you're
kind of in my way and i don't care if
you're a girl or extremely attractive
meow knowing the fact that matt reeves
is really borrowing a lot thematically
in character depiction-wise from batman
year one to me from the comics that i've
read the portrayal of catwoman while
brief in batman year one is one of the
most impressionable ones that's a taken
iteration that has always stuck with me
so i can imagine that if they are using
zoe kravitz and to riff off of that
version from batman year one i could see
why she'd be so impactful and i don't
get the sense of be playing up a love
story like maybe like sexual tension
love story i'm not sure they would do it
in this one but either way it's like if
it's anything like what it is and frank
miller's batman you're one then i'm sure
it'd be great to bring to the big screen
because there hasn't been any
interpretation that mirrors what was
there in batman year one a couple of
thoughts on robert pattinson himself as
batman they say their thoughts on robert
penson's batman voice his voice was
bad voice
we only just got taste of robert
pattinson's voice in that batman trailer
but i think it was the drop of the mic
that a lot of people had who were
doubting robert pattinson and still saw
him as the twilight boy because they
weren't seeing all his other new movies
that the second he beat up a thug and
then said the words a vengeance people
were like oh okay yeah this guy can be
batman and he's going to be a great
batman there's been a lot of controversy
amongst batman fans about this new
batmobile short and sweet their thoughts
on the robber panzer batman holy
i was one when they showed us the first
look at the batmobile that i loved it
not only because i am a guy who enjoys
muscle cars but i also yearn back to the
days where the batmobile was literally
just a car but from recent batman movies
they kind of revolutionized that they
need to turn it into a tank or this just
unbelievably big old heaping car so then
scaling it back down to a put together
car by robert pattinson himself at least
that's the details we've been told about
his bruce wayne that he basically makes
all his tech instead of getting it from
his company or someone like a lucius fox
i wanna see this thing in action drive
around the streets
that's more useful to him than a giant
tank that barely fits on the road two
more tidbits and details that he let us
know one is if there's a setup to a
sequel at the end he says here i just
asked if the batman sets up for a sequel
here's what they said yes def a sequel
that's the oh
moment i genuinely felt like they're
gonna start a whole collection of raw
bat pap movies and circle through
different villains maybe that's the only
way you do a batman trilogy and you know
what i say trilogy but this person here
is saying a whole collection of batman
movies warner brothers is at a point
where they know hey batman just tends to
make a lot of money if we make solo
batman movies and do it the right way
people will show up they'll make bank so
instead of just planning for a trilogy
and then waiting three four years and
then rebooting it with whatever actor is
hot then why not see how much we can
squeeze out of one actor hugh jackman's
style and make him batman for as long as
possible yeah we've heard matt reeve say
that they're at least aiming for a
trilogy that there's a very concise
story that they want to tell i imagine
that they could go longer considering
how early on in the batman story this is
starting but it doesn't surprise me at
all when they're talking about a rogue's
gallery being set up because the
impression that we've been getting is
that some of the villains are already
like inhabited within this world that
they're lived in it's not like cut away
and set up the origin of penguin let's
cut away and set up the origin catwoman
like riddler seems like he's already
doing riddler things you already got
oswald doing oswald things you got
selena kyle doing stuff so i imagine
that that's kind of the whole array of
what's going on in gotham is that a lot
of them are already planted and lived in
versus you know let's cut away to set up
an origin tale especially because a lot
of this already feels like it's
simultaneously borrowing from like
batman the long halloween which had a
similar vibe we'll see but i mean it's
no surprise at all they're sad for a
sequel but i do love is this guy's
tweets how every every comment is this
is the most epic thing ever freaking
awesome what do you think about the
music
which is the super target freak it's the
best knockout movie i've ever seen
the mobile's the best picture card so to
have it say here that they do set up for
a sequel and it feels like it'll be a
collection of villains that gets me so
excited because there's so many that we
haven't seen done or even reinvented
because like i got a kick out of arnold
schwarzenegger's mr freeze back in the
day but a serious version of that
character with the origin similar to the
animated series that has oscar potential
in my opinion maybe even some
lesser-known backgrounds batman
characters here for their final
statement on this batman movie they say
there's a scene at the end that
literally had everyone screaming
everyone gasped like it was a big no way
for everyone i don't give a f about
batman or dc i even clenched onto a knee
and was shook the biggest mic dropped
just hearing that makes me so upset that
this movie is gonna kill alfred or
something away the fact that he mentions
the batman movie must be for the setup
towards the end of the film it's just
this big hyper tension maybe he murders
the riddler screaming at clenching at
their knees all accumulating to a big
old mic drop either from the batman or
whatever other
as far as what it could be man i have no
idea whether this is connected to the
riddler and what was happening whether
maybe it's a secret villain that was
hidden from all the marketing thus far
joker there's rumors the joker somehow
makes an appearance in this movie
whether we want to believe that or not
but i feel like not every oh big moment
in batman's history has to involve the
joker but that is just some of the early
reactions we have to robert
october we are going to be getting a lot
more batman they're going to be
releasing some new stuff at dc band
poster finally who knows if they'll
release a trailer or maybe even a clip
of the film but next year man watching
the batman this is what people thought
about it i want to know what you guys
think don't forget to like subscribe
follow mentor at 3c films but as always
i'm chris take care
take care buddy fantastic breakdown
shouts out to blu-ray angel for all that
he put together there too man follow
blue ray angel on twitter as well he's
just a delightful personality i don't
think he follows me but whatever blu-ray
angel i'm not taking it personal i'm
taking it very personal i'm pretty upset
i should put this on camera maybe i
should have the video no i'm hoping you
watch the video and you follow me
because then when you do you'll have a
reaction as big and enthusiastic as it
is
oh my god this is the greatest flight of
history
this is better than blue check mark
all right guys
thanks so much for being here subscriber
3c films we'll catch you guys soon